[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ma
perché
Ah ci penso io
no no no no Mi scusi lo preso Oh
no ti abbiamo fregata oggi nuovissima
Challenge lavori in ordine alfabetico
oggi proverò vari lavori per 24 ore in
ordine alfabetico e dovrò rius a non
essere licenziata in più Dovrò riuscire
a tenere almeno cinque stelle da almeno
un cliente per ogni lavoro In più ci
saranno varie parole segrete durante
tutto il video quindi guardate il video
fino alla fine e Provate a scoprire
tutte le parole segrete cliccate un bel
mi piace e iniziamo subito con il primo
lavoro Il mio primo lavoro con la A è
animatrice Ma con chi dovrò lavorare Noi
siamo Nico è Lucy e io sono il più
simpatico dei due è vero sei antipatico
sono io tu sei antipatico ma che ti fa
ancora la Addo sei
tu fato
male basta basta basta basta oh no
questi ragazzini mi sembrano delle pezzi
sarà molto difficile fare l'animatrice e
babysitter a loro Ho un'idea li farò Gi
are con dei giochi volete degli
aeroplanini aeroplanini comandati VII
qua Ah io lo voglio quello rossa è mio
non
litigate Ma insomma Nico devi trattare
bene Tua sorella la mia responsabilità
ora è farvi da animatrice e se non
riuscirò a fare bene da animatrice a
questi due ragazzini i genitori
potrebbero licenziarmi e non lasceranno
le cinque stelle devo riuscire a passare
questo lavoro e dai giocate adesso così
sarete contenti sia voi che i vostri
genitori facciamo vediamo come volano
dai mi
ha maestra mi hai dato un aeroplanino
che non funziona Sei tu che non lo sai
usare No è la maestra
guarda Ma sei tornato indietro non è
vero
Anita basta basta litigare ho una
Challenge per voi perché non lanciate i
due planini e vediamo chi riesce ad
arrivare più lontano con l'aeroplanino
Sì io voglio quello rosso però va bene
Tanto vinco io non è vero Fammi vedere
che tu sei brava dai vediamo aspettate
vi porto io alla pista di lancio Andiamo
Ok adesso facciamo una gara di velocità
intanto vinco io chi arriva per ultimo
un caccavalle la mia
polvere Stanno ancora litigando quei due
ragazzini sono davvero delle pesti ho
paura che non riuscirò a superare
neanche il primo lavoro sta vincendo lei
S ha vinto io Mannaggia Sono arrivato
per ultimo Eh ma vedrai che la gara di
volo dell'aeroplanino la vinco io non
credo proprio ince Mi raccomando non
fate cadere gli aeroplanini sugli alberi
perché altrimenti non so come potremmo
recuperarli Ok va bene Pronti ai punti
di partenza 3 2 1 via
[Musica]
Guardate è camerato quello è quello dii
no
[Musica]
andato è precipitato anche il mio di là
Fa schifo questo gioco facciamo
qualcos'altro ce l'hai tu aspetta Dove
state andando non riesco a stare dietro
a questi ragazzini sono
scappati No vabbè Questo è è quello che
c'hanno pure pure a Disneyland no Lucy
Lucy Ca Non hai il coraggio di salire
qua e è pericolosissimo sì Non è vero
sei tu quello fifone dovresti farlo tu
no devi fare tu perché io lo so già che
che sarei bravissimo e invece te non ti
ho mai visto a usarlo eh E va bene lo
faccio io Eco vediamo
dai Non riesci neanche a
[Musica]
salire sono
bravissima che cosa state
facendo stavamo giocando con l'altalena
Ma come potreste farvi male ma io
intanto sono più bravo Non è vero Non è
vero Sono stata bravissima Io adesso Ora
basta siete in
punizione perché in punizione lui in
punizione obbligato mette sempre lei in
punizione a me no perché sono bravo No
basta ora siete in punizione e torniamo
in casa e farete i compiti i
compiti Non so neanche cosa siano i
compiti ma questa maestra io la odio è
colpa tua Miai sedere da unaa di
Disney non c'è altra soluzione devo per
forza metterle in punizione se voglio
passare questa prima Challenge Ehi ma
dove sono
finiti cosa stanno facendo
laggiù Stai pensando anche tu quello che
penso io Sì andiamo Anita vieni un
attimo Ehi Che cosa state facendo qua
Volevamo chiederti scusa scusa ci siamo
comportati male possiamo fare un gioco
insieme adesso E va bene Visto che me lo
lo chiedete così a cosa volete giocare
vorremmo vorremmo insegnarti un nuovo
gioco e È una versione speciale del
salto della corda l'abbiamo inventata
noi vieni qua vieni qua Nita vieni VII
Ok Allora tu devi stare qua dietro
dietro Nicco Scusa mi sono distratto lì
allora avvicinati un po'
all'albero quando devo saltare allora eh
diciamo fino a
a a cinque e poi e tu fai un urlo come
dire Yeah Viva Ok è un gioco che
funziona così eh pronta Allora 1 2 3 4
5 che cosa state facendo
[Applauso]
Fermi ti abbiamo fregata non siamo più
noi in punizione adesso rimarrei legata
qua e noi potremmo fare tutti i giochi
che vogliamo
sfigata andiamo Ciao Liberatemi Oh no E
adesso come faccio se non mi liberano e
rimango legata qua all'albero i genitori
mi licenzieranno e non riuscirò mai ad
avere le cinque stelle ma per fortuna
avevo preso con me il mio libro e ora
posso leggere la parola segreta e una
volta tradotta riuscirò a capire come
risolvere questa Challenge se voi non ce
l'avete ancora è ora disponibile onl e
lib
E ora vediamo qual è la parola segreta
guardate questa è la parola segreta Ora
non mi resta che tradurla con l'alfabeto
Cosa sta facendo Anita ha il libro
rubiamo glielo Sì non è giusto andiamo
Vai Cosa stai facendo con quel libro non
vi interessa sgat adesso Adesso è
[Applauso]
nostro
andiamo Vidale aiutami aiutami slegami i
ragazzini mi hanno
legato ti ho trovata finalmente Non puoi
capire che cosa è successo Non trovo più
la torta dove l'hai messa Ma cosa stai
dicendo torta slegami subito i due
ragazzini mi hanno legata Ti hanno
legato Ah non me nero accorto adesso
adesso Ti libero Ok sono libera ora
dobbiamo subito andare a vedere dove
sono finiti i due ragazzini andiamo
allora Dai andiamo andiamo Quanti giochi
qua dentro divertiamoci non ce ne anche
Aita
andiamo È bellissimo Guarda qua Uh Dai
giochiamo e eh Nico però poi possiamo
leggere anche questo libro va bene Lucy
però prima giochiamo dai Mettilo lì
adesso va bene Sei pronta Stai attento
vieni
qua Aspetta aspetta aspetta Facciamo che
ora tu sei la principessa e io vengo a
salvarti va bene A proposito di
principessa conoscete la storia di Shrek
noi saremo in scena l'8 dicembre al
Teatro Verde di Sassari con il musical
di shre io Saro mamma orso io cochino
Venite numerosi alle 11:00 del mattino
vi aspettiamo e potremmo farci anche
delle foto Sbrigatevi a ordinare i
biglietti sono nel link in descrizione
ti
aspettiamo Ma che stanno facendo stanno
giocando
combatti Aspetta aspetta leggiamo il
libro di adita adesso Oh sì
sì Mi è venuta un'idea che idea oltre
alla corda che avevano loro ho trovato
anche questa andiamo andiamo Seguimi
Guarda Lita adesso potranno leggere i
loro libri di scuola forza leggete
leggete leci dopo mi interrogo forza che
cosa dice qua dai Leggi anche tu
geografia Eh E tu invece matematica dai
leggi bravissimo Vitale Ottima idea Così
faranno i loro compiti leggeranno e non
potranno alzarsi dalla sedia così almeno
non combineranno uno dei loro guai
adesso l'unica cosa che ci tocca è
leggere questo libro Eh vabbè Allora
leggiamo Scusa non possiamo fare altro
va
bene prossimo
lavoro
parrucchiera siamo riusciti a superare
il primo lavoro con le cinque stelline
Ma c'è mancato poco ad essere licenziati
e Ora dovrò fare la parrucchiera
Speriamo che questo lavoro sia più
facile ma io non ho mai tagliato i
capelli a qualcuno in vita mia come farò
adesso cliccate mi piace per portarmi
fortuna Ecco la prima cliente
Salve buonasera Benvenuta Piacere Maria
Anita Sono la nuova parrucchiera pera si
sieda si
sieda allora eh Che tipo di taglio
vorrebbe Allora ti dico subito voglio
cambiare tutto vorrei i capelli un po'
più corti tipo qua però non troppo
facciamo Oh no Non ho capito niente come
devo farglieli questi capelli Eh sì
quindi più corti e poi e poi vorrei un
pochino più di volume però Non troppo
perché poi non voglio sembrare una
scoopa insomma eh oltretutto non so
questo colore magari è un pochino più
chiaro però non troppo Ok magari anche
un po' più scuro da lei su insomma le le
ho dato le indicazioni Ok Credo di aver
capito Iniziamo con questo speriamo che
vada bene quindi io un pochino più corti
ma non troppo Ok un pochino e forse un
po' più lunghi anche
Ok ci penso io deve essere facile Questa
devo semplicemente tagliarli più
[Musica]
corti Ok il taglio è pronto posso
guardarmi certo
Ah ma sono
orribile sembro un gatto spennacchiato
ma cosa hai fatto ai miei capelli io
Adesso lascio una recensione negativa Io
non pago niente no no no no no no
aspetta aspetta non puoi lasciare una
recensione negativa altrimenti mi
licenzieranno Ma guarda cosa hai fatto i
miei capelli ma è quello che mi ha
chiesto Ehi ha detto un po' più corti un
po' più lunghi non capito niente Non è
vero è cheo un po' più corti ma lo
stesso seme un po' più lungi un po' un
po' più più volume ma lo stesso Oh no E
adesso come faccio ah eccomi qua Scusate
ho fatto tardi io sono Gabriel stylist
il padrone di questo salone di bellezza
e parrucchieri Ma che succede qua cosa
hai fatto signora mi ha rovinato i
capelli No no no Non si preoccupi lei
adesso le offriamo tutto e torni a casa
e meta una recensione positiva non si
preoccupi Eh no no no no Io metterò una
recensione negativa Assolutamente no
signora è nuova lei non capisce vada
vada vedrà che tutto andrà meglio eh mi
raccomando eh Buona serata metterò
sicuramente una stella Ciao Oh no ma ma
come ti sei permessa a tagliare i
capelli così ma insomma mio zio col
trattore li avrebbe tagliati meglio e
dai il cliente paga il cliente sacro Il
cliente ha sempre ragione non è colpa
mia È che non erano molto chiare le
indicazioni che ha dato mi interessa Tu
taga un'altra volta i capelli così a un
cliente e io ti licenzio oh no devo
assolutamente riuscire a non essere
licenziata e devo prendere anche cinque
stelle altrimenti avrò fallito la
seconda Challenge Ciao Anita Meno male
Ti ho trovata Sono qui per aiutarti in
questo lavoro che cosa dobbiamo fare
Ciao Vitale Ok perfetto Aiutami tu siamo
nel salone da parrucchieri dobbiamo fare
i parrucchieri e siccome prima è andata
molto male Ora prova tu a tagliare i
capelli io nel frattempo leggo un
manuale da parrucchieri così Imparerò a
tagliare meglio i capelli Ok va bene va
bene alla la prossima cliente ci penso
io nessun problema vai pure a studiare
Mi raccomando stai attento Non dobbiamo
Essere licenziati dobbiamo avere cinque
stelline
vado Salve Ah Salve e come posso
aiutarla piacere Ornella piacere Sono
Vitale Eh vorrei cambiare i capelli
ormai sono diventati ingestibili e non
riesco neanche più a pettinarli Prego
Prego si accomodi ci penso io ci penso
proprio io Prego si accomodi eh Ora
prendo subito il telo così possiamo
iniziare con il taglio Ah Sono proprio
stanca di questi capelli non ne posso
più troppe doppie punte e e sono crespy
ingestibili Non si preoccupi ci penso io
sono molto bravo in questo Allora
mettiamo subito il telo Questo è il telo
del mio scooter per coprirlo quando
piove modo un po' insolito di mettere un
telo però va bene Ah non si preoccupi
quindi mi diceva come li vuole questi
capelli Non lo so faccia lei Io sono
proprio stanca di questi capelli non
riesco neanche più a pettinarli Oh è
stanca di questi capelli Non si
preoccupi ci penso
[Musica]
io
Uh stanno venendo benissimo e ci siamo
quasi quasi finito e
perfetto adesso i capelli non le daranno
più problema
Voilà Ah ma cosa hai fatto sono i miei
capelli eh Le ho tagliato i capelli me
l'ha detto lei che le davano fastidio
così non le danno più fastidio No ma io
non intendevo questo eh Signora mi scusi
prima prima che si
arrabbi mi potrebbe lasciare Cinque
Stelle per favore Assolutamente
no perché no lascerò sicuramente una
recensione negativa basta Io me ne vado
ma me l'ha detto lei che le davano
fastidio a capelli le ho risolto il
problema Vitale Come'è andato
ah
perché quella cliente È pelata e me l'ha
chiesto lei di tagliarle i capelli Io le
ho solo fatto un favore a tagliargli
tutti No però è andata via arrabbiata Oh
no Speriamo solo che il capo non lo
Scosa cos'è questa recensione negativa
sul sito del nostro locale del mio
locale Anzi avete tagliato di nuovo male
i capelli a qualcuno no dove essersi
sbagliata magari si riferiva a un altro
parrucchiere non credo qua Siamo il top
del top ci sono solo io qua com'è
possibile una stella basta Fatene ancora
una aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta non
ci licenzi ancora mi lasci un'ultima
possibilità Ok Un'ultima cliente
prometto che farò benissimo i capelli e
va bene ma l'ultima poi daremo un taglio
al personale un taglio capito che
simpatico Ah ce la siamo vista brutta ma
questa è l'ultima possibilità tu Vitale
non tagliare più i capelli Ok ci penso
io E va bene va bene mi tolgo di mezzo
adesso però ho un'idea Magari prova a
dare un'occhiata al libro per scoprire
Qual è la parola segreta così magari
riusciamo a superare questa Challenge eh
buona idea vediamo qual è la parola
segreta per questa seconda
Challenge Eccola Questa è la parola
segreta mettete pausa anche voi e traduc
etela con il libro Credo di aver capito
cosa devo fare ecco che arriva la nuova
cliente questa volta ce la farò prego
salve salve E che cosa desidera oggi
io oggi vorrei una semplice piega ok
Molto più semplice di un taglio e certo
non c'è problema si sieda pure Grazie la
piega liscia o mossa liscia grazie Ok
non c'è problema Questa dovrebbe essere
facile con la piastra iniziamo con la
prima
gioca è tutto a posto qua son venuto a
controllare
Sì sì tutto perfetto devo semplicemente
piastrare dei capelli bene Buongiorno
signora si trova bene Qua sì la
parrucchierea è molto gentile Ah mi fa
piacere Ti ricordi di lasciare una
recensione sul nostro sito certamente Vi
lascio continuare Buona
serata stanno uscendo benissimo Guardate
che lisci Spero proprio che questa volta
avrò una recensione 5 Stelle Anzi resto
qua voglio controllare il lavoro nei
dettagli Uffa adesso mi viene l'ansia Se
il capo si mette a controllare tutto C'è
odore di bruciato qua No no non è
possibile non sto mica bruciando niente
mm e questa è meglio che ma insomma sei
uno stylist Dovresti sapere che la
cestra brucia Ah sì certo lo sapevo Ecco
certo che tu sei il capo parrucchiere
uno Stylist con quella frangetta quella
frangetta Ma come ti permetti Questa è
una capigliatura all'ultimo grido au
sono alla moda io non come te signora
non l'ascolti è nuova qua Se lo dici tu
di essere alla moda ho quasi fatto
Guarda che belli i capelli sono usciti
liscissimi sono non sono
bellissimi Sì sono usciti bene ma è la
signora che deve dircelo ha quasi finito
Tra poco vediamo se lascerà una
recensione 5 Stelle Così potrò
finalmente passare alla prossima
Challenge ed ecco fatto Guardate che
lisci questi capelli ma ora l'
importante è che la cliente si piaccia
così lascierà 5 Stelle allora e le
piacciono i nuovi capelli guardi che
lisci che sono le piacciono le piacciono
ma sono bellissimi
grazie Mi piacciono tantissimo Ah grazie
lascerò sicuramente una recensione
positiva Sì C stelle oh sì grazie mille
grazie arrivederci arrivederci quindi
non sono licenziata vero non me
l'aspettavo però lasciata la recensione
di 5 stelle quindi si guadagna Va bene
dai Non ti diceno Bena abbiamo superato
questa seconda Challenge passiamo ora
alla terza e ultima
Challenge Qual è il nostro terzo lavoro
siamo in una cucina che bello una cucina
che bello Non vedevo l'ora Finalmente
posso mangiare da dove cominciamo che
cosa mi mangio eh eh no no no no no no
no non devi mangiare Siamo in un
ristorante dobbiamo fare il nostro
lavoro Io sono la cameriera E tu sei il
cuoco Quindi tu devi cucinare il cibo e
io devo portare il cibo ai clienti Mi
raccomando non dobbiamo Essere
licenziati e dobbiamo ricevere le cinque
stelle chissà quale sarà la parola
segreta qua presto sbrighiamoci sta già
entrando una cliente prego prego
Benvenuta al ristorante pizzeria Tutto
fatto a casa mia buonasera e Prego si
sieda pure in questo tavolo picc
piccolino
Eh sì purtroppo questo è l'unico spazio
che abbiamo ma non ti preoccupi perché
prepariamo tutto noi con le nostre
mani va bene grazie eh Dia pure
un'occhiata al menù e le prepareremo
subito il piatto che preferisce ma
proprio davanti al muro dovevate
mettermi non mi sembra il posto adeguato
Eh mi dispiace Purtroppo questo
ristorante è un po' piccolino Però una
volta che avrà assaggiato il cibo di
questo ristorante sicuramente ci Cà 5
Stelle vero Lo spero Portatemi
immediatamente il piatto della casa se
non lo preparate entro 5 minuti io me ne
vado sì sì sì sì certo faccio subito
presto presto presto presto presto 5
minuti Il tempo scorre prego spero che
Vitale sia veloce Vitale Vitale ma cosa
stai facendo Stai mangiando eh Sto
mangiando l'insalata presto presto
Sbrigati la prima cliente ha detto che
se non li prepariamo subito il piatto
entro 5 minuti se ne andrà via via e se
se ne va via vuol dire che ci lascerà
una recensione di una stella e potremmo
Essere licenziati Sbrigati prepara
subito qualcosa Ok io cerco di tenerla
distratta nel frattempo Sì sì ci penso
io non ti preoccupare adesso ci penso io
che cosa da preparo Uffa Ma quanto ci
mettono Io tra poco me ne vado via Ecco
Lita è pronto è
pronto Voilà Guarda che bello è perfetto
guarda portaglielo portaglielo subito
alla cliente prima che se ne vada dai Ma
sei sicuro sembra che manchino degli
ingredienti a questo panino Ah no no c'è
tutto devo sbrigarmi devo sbrigarmi
Vai 10 9 5 4 EC Ecco eccolo ecc Ops
Scusi Scusi Scusi Scusi eh aspetti
aspetti un momento gliela pulisco eh Eh
no aspetta las Allora ecco il piatto
della casa un buonissimo panino fatto in
casa finalmente quanto ci voleva spero
che gli piaccia anche perché abbiamo
bisogno di una recensione 5 stelle
quindi se le piace questo farino potrà
subito lasciarci una recensione 5 Stelle
lo assaggerò cinque stelle cinque stelle
cinque stelle cinque stelle ma è
Terribile come terribile sai cosa ci
faccio io con questo panino che
cosa Ah ma perché non pensavo che fosse
così male questo panino fine che si
meritano I vostri piatti devo subito
andare a parlare con chef Vitale
rimedieremo subito con un buonissimo
dessert Ok non lasci la recensione una
stella eh mi raccomando non lasci
nessuna recensione negativa Torno subito
con il destere Speriamo almeno questo
sia
commestibile Vital Ma cosa hai combinato
Guarda come l'hai preparato questo
panino ti sei dimenticato gli
ingredienti c'è solo il ketchup Guarda
che cosa ho subito ma come solo il il
ketchup non lo vedi che c'è anche
l'insalata ce NH hai anche una foglia in
faccia E dai non ti preoccupare per i
prossimi piatti non mangerò più gli
ingredienti Eh volevo dire li preparerò
meglio molto meglio Sì
sì Sento odore di fallimento e anche un
po' di Buffa sono Gordon il più grande
critico culinario del mondo e sono qui
per giudicare questo ristorante da meno
due stelle
ma quello è Gordon il più grande critico
gastronomico Dobbiamo assolutamente fare
bella figura con lui se ci lasciasse una
recensione positiva il capo sarebbe
felicissimo e non ci licenzierei
devo sistemarmi subito Vai ad
accoglierlo presto
vai Eccomi
eccomi come si permette Meo due stelle
Ah lei non sa come cucino io e lei non
sa chi sono io dov'è il mio tappeto
rosso Voglio il tavolo migliore Eh il
tavolo migliore è quello e quindi ho
capito faccio da solo ma dove siamo
finiti con la male educazione e Eccomi
eccomi signor Gordon prego L'accompagno
io al tavolo si può sedere qua al nostro
è il nostro tavolo migliore FR Grazie
Finalmente qualcuno si è accorto di me
Oggi abbiamo il piatto della casa e ed è
un buonissimo non mi ricordo che un po'
scomode queste sedie no Eh sì ma deve
sapere che siamo un piccolo ristorante
Eh sì ho
notato
datemi il vostro piatto migliore ok eh
Non c'è problema li porto subito il
nostro piatto migliore Arrivo subito per
ora il mio voto alla location è zero c'è
addirittura la muffa le crepe sui muri
Che vergogna Ma cosa ci fa Gom critico
gastronomico famosissimo in questo
locale da due soldi me lo chiedo anch'io
È solo che sto facendo una ricerca per
trovare un nuovo spazio per il mio nuovo
ristorante e questo è un locale perfetto
per essere
demolito Ora basta Quanto ci vuole a
preparare un dessert io Adesso lascio
una recensione negativa e me ne vado
arrivederci Ma ma questa questa è acqua
di fogna che schifo B La tovaglia ma non
siamo mica da mia nonna per carità le
forchette non hanno neanche la
luminosità giusta è un oltraggio alla
cucina Anita Anita ho preparato un
piatto speciale per il nostro critico e
portaglielo subito però non lo aprire eh
aprilo davanti a lui ok spero solo che
ti sei impegnato perché altrimenti ci
licenzieranno non so cosa ci sia qua
sotto ma mi fido di te con la nuova
tecnica sperimentale testerò se queste
forchette sono veramente in acciaio
affidabile Ma cosa sta facendo ma si fa
i trucchi del mestiere non vanno
raccontati a lei allora il cuoco mi ha
detto che ha preparato un piatto
speciale Solo per lei quindi spero tanto
che le piaccia e ovviamente se le piace
Ci lasci una recensione 5 Stelle sì è
tutto da vedere anche se partite già con
zero punti Oh
no Così impara avrà una bella sorpresa
quel critico antipatico adesso Ecco qua
è un piatto speciale apposta per lei
T
Ma che cosa ha combinato Vitale è uno
scherzo è uno scherzo questo vero no no
no no no Ma come vi permettete a me Eh
no è che in realtà questo qua è un
famosissimo sandwich Teresa Che cos'è se
lo mangi lei Vediamo se le piace davvero
Ecco
eh Ok non c'è
problema
mm è buonissimo mm ti consiglio di
assaggiarlo adesso che l'hai mangiato tu
ma per favore Torna in cucina e
Portatemi un altro piatto Non c'è più
rispetto dall'autorità Ok arrivo
subito cosa sta succedendo nel mio
ristorante perché tutti i clienti se ne
stanno
andando No È che semplicemente che cos'è
questo è quello che voleva darmi il suo
cuoco se semra il caso mi sembra il caso
di presentare una cosa così Eh glielo
dica una cipolla con del pane
Mi scusi ci deve essere sicuramente
stato un errore Sì un errore un errore
errore o no questo ristorante avrà da me
Zero stelle sicuro Arrivederci
No Cosa hai fatto Anita No no Non lo so
cosa è successo forse il cuoco si è
sentito male quello era un grande
critico poteva essere la nostra
occasione di mandare avanti il locale e
invece Guardate cosa avete combinato
l'unica cosa da fare adesso è
licenziare non ci licenzi non ci licenzi
ora rimediamo a i prossimi clienti
prepareremo qualcosa di buonissimo va
bene ma se non è così vi licenzierò Ok
vado subito ad avvisare il
cuoco Vitale Ma come ti sei permesso a
fare un piatto del genere al grande
critico gastronomico la k ha detto che
se sbagliamo ancora una volta ci
licenzierà e non potremmo passare la
Challenge Eh no è che io in pratica
praticamente C'è qualcuno C'è
qualcuno permesso altri clienti presto
devo sbrigarmi
Sì sì prego accomodatevi pure e dove
siamo qui ma cosa siamo Alle poste qua
eh alle porte
siamo Alle
poste Benvenuti al nostro ristorante ror
è bella Hai visto bella ragaz Ma tu Pote
di Antonietta sì Eh no di garvina di
garvina di Gina Sì sì sì sì certo prego
prego sedetevi sedetevi pure ai poti
[Musica]
prego Ah e qua cosa cucinate gatti no no
no no Mi scusi che Oh non riesco a
sedermi datemi una mano che C
[Musica]
Aspetta adesso va bravi è che essendo un
ristorante familiare ci sono anche i
nostri amici animali ma non vi
preoccupate ora vi prepariamo subito
qualcosa eh possiamo fare noi sì però mi
raccomando A noi non piace la cucina
moderna quindi tradizionale Ecco ok Eh
certo non c'è problema ora parlo subito
con il cuoco Torno subito ma le pastig
Non lo so le pastiglie le hai portate Eh
le pastiglie eh Le
Pastin la pastina no no no pastina no si
può Guarda Beh Vitale Vitale Questa è la
nostra occasione sono appena entrati due
clienti due vecchietti dolcissimi e
adorabili è la nostra occasione per
avere le cinque stelle non Essere
licenziati però loro vogliono qualcosa
di tradizionale Quindi mi raccomando
prepara subito qualcosa di tradizionale
tradizionale Beh ma che cosa c'è di più
tradizionale di questo
eh Un po' di pane Guarda è già
pronto tieni portagli subito Ok ok Vado
speriamo che gli piaccia Almeno questo
Eccomi eccomi qua questa è proprio una
cosa super tradizionale il pane Ecco qua
tutto per voi cara non abbiamo idente m
c'è anche lui che lo apprezzo Oh
no scusate scusate
dovete no fa niente a casa me anche il
nostro cane fa così Noi non c'abbiamo i
denti e ce lo mangia lui noi lo possiamo
mangiare
SC Meno male L'hanno presa bene questi
due vecchietti Ok quindi voi non potete
mangiarlo Ma no non abbiamo i denti come
facciamo Ok non c'è problema vi poro
subito qualcos'altro ma non lasciate una
recensione negativa Eh che cosa Ah non
sapete che cos'è la pensione negativa Sì
sì e quella positiva Grazie
cara Ormai sono più di 60 anni che Samo
in insieme Ho deciso di regalarti questo
qua Oh che belli Ecco ti
piace Ecco se vuoi puoi tenerti pure il
vaso
Ah che cosa preparo per il prossimo
piatto guardo nel libro Magari scopro la
parola
segreta guardate questa è la parola
segreta di questa Challenge traducete
anche voi Aprite il libro alla pagina
dell'alfabeto Segreto e scoprite che
cosa cosa c'è scritto Ah qua mi ricorda
proprio casa Questo ristorante è
veramente bello Guarda la tagna s ci sta
proprio bene guarda i bicchieri che
belli me l'ho porta a casa questo ci sta
bene Mi con la l'arredamento vitale i
clienti non hanno i denti come facciamo
adesso cosa puoi preparargli è la nostra
ultima occasione Non ti preoccupare c'ho
già pensato io una bella zuppa Guarda
eh Con questa non avranno problemi
portaglielo portaglielo dai Ottima idea
Vitale Questa forse è la nostra
occasione Vediamo se gli piacerà questa
zuppa Vai vai Speriamo bene ecco
qua piatto per voi una
buonissima zuppa no no no no Merlino
Merlino Stavamo giusto commentando
quanto si sta bene qua dentro proprio
complimenti Grazie grazie Ci meritiamo
proprio cinque stelle Cosa significa eh
Te lo spiego dopo Adesso assaggiate pure
il piatto Vediamo se gli
piace mm che buon
profumo
prelibata Allora vi piace Buon buona
buona Eh come la faceva mamma EV viva
quindi ora ci lasciate una recensione
cin stelle che ci dici cosa vuol dirci
vi che lo lasciamo Vai quello che vuoi
sì S devo subito informare cuoco Vitale
la zuppa è stato un successo Credo
proprio che ci lasceranno C stelle vado
subito a controllare Allora siete stati
bene Benissimo torneremo
Sicuramente ma ci lascerete una
recensione 5 Stelle Cos'è che dobbiamo
lasciare una recensione 5 Stelle Eh
vabbè sì ci facciamo dire la nostra
nipote cosa è questa cosa per
Perfetto grazie mille e tornate pure
quant volete Arrivederci hai saluta tua
mamma Elisabetta certo ciao ciao
Challenge superata abbiamo vinto la
Challenge cinque stelle scriveteci nei
commenti Qual è stato il vostro momento
preferito e ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
casellini su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione Ciao ciao